hey guys it's justine and we're back in
the new studio with the first tv
unboxing and i cannot wait because this
is something that the studio needed we
really needed a new television to
brighten up this space and i could not
be more excited because this is one of
the new lg qned mini led tvs i did see
some early prototypes over the years of
mini led tvs and i can't wait because
guess what it is here in the studio and
we're gonna unbox it and set it up and
check it out and i was kind of just like
walking around the box checking out the
specs seeing what i can see look
this is the new
magic remote with nfc thanks to lg for
sponsoring this video and giving this
new tv a wonderful new home
i don't think i've even cut the tape
i've just cut the box
some assembly looks to be required
oh no
oh boy
okay yep
yep oh i just missed trash day yeah i'll
just um there that's nice
all right little tv that is not so
little welcome to your new home all
right so it looks like we may i may need
a small assist
a little heavier than i thought
[Music]
well the legs are on i think i'm
actually going to set it up right here
on this desk and this can be kind of
like the studio tv
oh
my
[Laughter]
[Music]
i also just realized in the intro that i
didn't tell you guys that this is an 8k
television oh there's another sticky
satisfying
so we have it all set up it's plugged in
i can't wait to see what this thing
looks like i am interested to see how
this nfc remote works press the ok
button wheel on your remote volume 15 19
20.
[Applause]
whoa
oh my gosh lg's deep learning technology
can enhance image clarity and resolution
according to whoa i definitely heard a
huge difference see if you guys can hear
a difference
[Music]
this is without the sound pro turned on
whoa
[Applause]
that's incredible so i connected my tv
to the thin cue app which connects all
of my other lg devices together like my
washer my dryer my lg styler and even my
vacuum so i can actually get a
notification on my tv when my clothes
are done in the washer or dryer i know
pretty awesome i think now it's finally
time to watch something
whoa this
looks
absolutely
oh my god
[Music]
like i've done a lot of video reviews on
tvs before but like
actually sitting here
and seeing the freaking future
so this is my first mini led tv and this
type of tv tech just recently started
rolling out into the mainstream we've
pretty quickly evolved from crt to the
backlit tv using lcd and oled with self
lighting pixels the difference with mini
led is that they are about 1 40th the
size of a regular led there's also
greater control over dimming zones
leading to much deeper blacks and a
higher contrast ratio than other types
of led tvs it is really difficult to
show you how incredible this picture
quality is through a youtube video but
having this be my first experience with
a mini led tv i'm absolutely blown away
[Music]
these colors are so incredibly vibrant
and the thing i love about hdr is it
really does give you that just
impressive color range like these blacks
that actually doesn't even look like the
tv is on like you don't even see
anything i'm even so close to this tv
but like the detail everything is so
crisp like i can watch this tv from here
i mean you probably shouldn't do that
but i could one of the things i love
about smart tvs is all of the built-in
apps it's really cool because this
actually does have apple tv built in so
you can enjoy all of the apple tv
content there's even lg fitness and of
course you can install any of your
favorite streaming services even the
remote now has netflix prime video
disney plus lg channels it has alexa and
google built directly into the remote
and i love the new nfc feature so you
can share content directly from the
remote to your tv we can also do airplay
directly from our phone to the tv so i'm
gonna airplay a piece of content
just a little knife fight action no big
deal
i love that i can just talk to my tv by
pressing this little microphone button i
can change settings i can adjust the
volume and i can even fix a leaky faucet
how do i fix a leaky faucet
[Music]
oh yeah
i'm gonna fix that leaky faucet maybe
even
how do i get rid of ants
looks like some of these people have
even more issues than i do set volume to
pretty cool
thank you
look up thank you in youtube that's not
i okay
the viewing angle is also pretty
impressive so even if i'm like kind of
right off here to the side like you're
still gonna be getting an incredible
view of this tv hey
tyler can you hear the lights real quick
[Music]
oh this is a cinematic viewing
experience if i've ever had one this is
just what the studio needed
[Music]
the entire design of this tv is
beautiful with minimal bezels and a
super slim design with this quantum dot
nano cell display full array dimming
using the alpha 9 gen 4 processor 8k
this gives you an immersive viewing
experience it also features dolby vision
iq and dolby atmos for the best in class
hdr and as a creator myself i love when
a tv has a filmmaker mode this turns off
motion smoothing and preserves original
aspect ratios colors and frame rates
that the creator intended with hdmi 2.1
and game optimizer you'll get the best
viewing experience with picture quality
that optimizes depending upon the genre
of game you're playing well thank you
guys so much for watching i'm going to
put a link in the description if you
want to check out more information about
this tv and all of the amazing things
that lg has to offer and with that my
friends i will see you in the next video
and i'll just be right here watching tv
i
love watching tv